the situation along ukraine's border
appears to be deteriorating in rapid
fashion with u.s intelligence agencies
now fearful that russia has amassed
large enough posture that it could act
militarily in a reasonably swift fashion
the speculation had been that any
movement by moscow could happen after
the beijing games but in warning
americans to vacate ukraine there's a
more stringent sense of urgency the
pentagon has now confirmed a secondary
deployment of military personnel to
nato's eastern flank bringing the total
numbers to around five thousand these
troops will not fight with ukrainian
soldiers or against russia but instead
defend nato territory now after a week
of shuttle diplomacy that failed to make
any breakthroughs president joe biden
convened a meeting with nato and eu
allies on friday that included the prime
minister pledging to protect ukrainian
sovereignty and consequences should
russia strike russia must de-escalate
the west is standing firm together
coordinated and ready to impose severe
costs including sanctions
if russia
invades ukraine once again we are not
saying that a decision has been taken a
final decision has been taken by
president putin what we are saying is
that we have a sufficient level of
concern based on what we are seeing on
the ground that assessment runs counter
to reporting that the kremlin has
already made a decision to invade u.s
military and intelligence officials
believe any incursion would likely
include ground and air attacks and could
target the capital of kiev but also fear
the use of cyber warfare to further
destabilize ukraine and potentially its
allies reggie shakini global news
washington